[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con el 2050
es el nombre de la estrategia climática
de largo plazo que colombia ha
implementado con el fin de alcanzar los
objetivos del acuerdo de parís entre
ellos limitar el aumento de la
temperatura global y reducir las
emisiones de co2 para el año 2050 en el
proceso de implementación de la
estrategia en colombia francia es un
aliado del país sudamericano para hablar
sobre este tema nos acompaña nicolás n
director del departamento de desarrollo
sostenible de expert seasons agencia
pública francesa para la concepción y
puesta en marcha de proyectos
internacionales de cooperación técnica
buenos días señor sheen háblenos del
trabajo de expertise hans y del tipo de
proyectos que realizan en el mundo
porque tú permite hola muchas gracias
por esta oportunidad en expertise
friends somos una agencia de
implementación de desarrollo
internacional una agencia pública
nuestro trabajo es diseñar e implementar
proyectos de desarrollo en todo el mundo
en temas relacionados con la cooperación
internacional al llegar a compras falta
nacional post impulsan en lo que a mí
respecta soy el director del
departamento de desarrollo sostenible
por lo que nuestro papel más específico
es tratar de conectar los retos y las
negociaciones internacionales los
compromisos adquiridos por los estados
oa nivel internacional sobre el clima y
la biodiversidad por ejemplo con los
proyectos sobre el terreno y garantizar
que haya coherencia entre los
compromisos adquiridos a nivel
internacional y nacional y lo que ocurre
en los proyectos en el terreno
señor tiene por qué y cómo trabaja
expertise hands para combatir el cambio
climático en colombia
trabajamos frencia trabajado de manera
general en la lucha contra el cambio
climático en muchos países efectivamente
tras la cob 21 y el acuerdo de parís que
se derivó de ella gracias ha sido
impulsora de este compromiso incluyendo
todos los países del mundo para tratar
de limitar la emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero para que lleguemos a menos
de 2 grados de aumento de temperatura en
esta trayectoria por lo tanto a todos
los países le concierne este compromiso
por lo que el papel de francia es
también apoyar a los países que lo
deseen y que estén dispuestos a dar este
paso para reducir sus emisiones en lo
que respecta a colombia más
concretamente tenemos la suerte de
contar con un país que ha sido
especialmente impulsor sobre todo en la
región y que tenía unos compromisos
importantísimos y les hemos ayudado a
concretar los modelando una trayectoria
de neutralidad en carbono y de capital
natural positivo para 2050 una
trayectoria que por supuesto está
consolidada por modelos y modelación es
técnicas que nos permiten sustentar esta
trayectoria por lo que este es nuestro
trabajo aquí en colombia cómo lo podemos
hacer en otros países del mundo por lo
que el objetivo es que el máximo número
de países se comprometen con esta
trayectoria baja en carbono para que
podamos respetar los compromisos del
acuerdo de parís
con fiscales han respondido lectura
cómicos el presidente de colombia iván
duque presentó en la cop 26 una
estrategia climática a largo plazo
llamada 2050 de qué se trata y por qué
participa francia en su desarrollo un
deber
y esta estrategia a largo plazo es un
complemento de los compromisos asumidos
en la con 21 que se denominaron cdn o n
dc por sus siglas en inglés es decir
contribuciones determinadas a nivel
nacional que establecían compromisos a
corto plazo a veces hasta 2025 o 2030
para que los países redujeran sus
emisiones una de las conclusiones fue
que también era muy importante trabajar
en compromisos a largo plazo para
políticas más transformadoras
especialmente en el ámbito de por
ejemplo la matriz energética de los
países o las transformaciones en
relación con el uso del sueño así que
era muy importante que también
trabajaremos con los países que quieren
asumir compromisos a más largo por
ejemplo para 2050 creo que pudimos
trabajar con muchos países en particular
aquí en colombia en este tipo de
trayectorias entonces sí que fue una
elección por parte de la comunidad
internacional y de francia materializar
trayectorias a más largo plazo para
poder tener una transformación más
profunda de los problemas del cambio
climático en el tiempo con sanción
automática y por último cuáles cree que
son los retos de la estrategia 2050 para
su aplicación los retos son desde ya que
todo el mundo se apropia de esta
estrategia por eso también tengo la
suerte de estar hoy aquí con ustedes
porque realmente necesitamos que el
mayor número de personas en colombia se
sientan concernidos por este tema y es
sumamente importante que difundamos esta
estrategia para que sea bien entendida y
apropiada por el mayor número de
personas posible el siguiente desafío
será monitorear esa trayectoria y esta
estrategia que se ha puesto en marcha
para producir datos confiables que son
producidos por organizaciones como el
ideam y que nos ayudarán a dirigir esta
estrategia que ayudarán al gobierno
colombiano a monitorear las el último
reto que yo diría es efectivamente esta
capacidad que vamos a tener de
territorio usar esta estrategia es decir
de declinar la de acuerdo con las
diferentes regiones que podemos tener
aquí en colombia que obviamente tienen
diferentes perfiles y tienen diferentes
objetivos de acuerdo con las regiones y
territorios en los que colombia quiere
implementar esta estrategia todavía
tenemos bastantes retos por delante
colombia está bien encaminada y tenemos
una voluntad muy fuerte de alcanzar este
objetivo es completamente sostenible
para el año 2050
así muchas gracias señor cine por estar
con nosotros y a ustedes los invito a
que sigan con nosotros en france 24
[Aplausos]
[Música]